quand
et dire qu'elle faisait là pendant tout
ce temps absolument partout autour de
moi et que je ne les voyait pas et dire
qu'elle était là avec tous leurs trésors
le rusé leur histoire et que je m'en
foutais de temps à autre quand quelqu'un
a attiré mon attention sur l'une d'elles
le vague intérêt que je lui portais un
instant s'évanouissent et au gré du vol
d'un insecte ou d'une vibration de mon
téléphone quand je regardais les plantes
autour de moi c'était comme si
j'écoutais une chanson dans une langue
inconnue
je pouvais être sensibles à leur beauté
à leur étrangeté
mais rapidement ça me semblait un petit
peu monotone la plupart du temps une
plante sévère et ça ne bouge pas comme
la plupart des gens mon attention se
porter plus volontiers sur les animaux
quand j'étais enfant on m'a posé mille
fois la question quel est ton animal
préféré
mais jamais la question quelle est ta
plante préférée
et c'est vrai que les animaux nous
ressemble on s'attache facilement eux on
leur prête même souvent des sentiments
humains
les plantes au contraire c'est un monde
étranger elle représente plus de 80 % de
la biomasse totale sur terre et pourtant
la plupart du temps nous les voyons
comme le papier peint du paysage comme
du mobilier urbain agréable certes mais
pas vraiment digne d'attention c'est un
biais cognitifs qu'on appelle ses sites
et botanique
on parle aussi deux au centrisme voire
deux au chauvinisme est historiquement
c'est un phénomène qui a tendance à
s'accentuer au fil du temps et on peut
le constater en observant le déclin
vertigineux de l'enseignement de la
botanique
pour vous donner un exemple en 2009 au
royaume uni 19 étudiants ont effectué un
stage en botanique
ils étaient plus d'un millier en
zoologie alors bien évidemment ce ne
serait pas un problème si le sujet était
anodin attendait parce que ça va devenir
sérieux j'ai prévu que vous stresse y
ait non plus c'est de trouver un juste
milieu
il y a des problèmes mais souvenez vous
de garder le coeur léger on va régler
tout ça ensemble sereinement
donc je disais ce ne serait pas un
problème si le sujet était anodin mais
les plantes ont grand besoin de
protection et nous pourrions être en
mesure de leur fournir
et pas seulement pour tous les services
qu'elles nous rendent au quotidien mais
puisqu'on connaît si mal les plantes
pourquoi voudrait-on les protéger en
2011 aux états unis
les plantes représenté 57% des espèces
menacées et n'ont obtenu que 4 % à peine
des fonds consacrés à la sauvegarde de
la biodiversité
à ce jour les plantes disparaissent 500
fois plus vite que leur rythme
historique depuis 1750 sont près de 600
espèces végétales qui ont disparu c'est
deux fois plus que les oiseaux les
mammifères et les amphibiens réunis et
pourtant qui d'entre nous peut citer une
seule de ces plantes disparues il ya
donc deux tragédies celle de perdre les
plantes et celle de perdre la
connaissance des plantes globalement
collectivement nous permettons cela pire
encore notre illettrisme botanique nous
conduit à des comportements à risque on
achète des plantes à tire larigot sans
vraiment les connaître la toquade d'une
forme la séduction d'un bas prix il n'en
faut pas plus pour nous convaincre
à ce jour en australie les plantes
ornementales représentent 65% des
espèces introduites et pourquoi je parle
de comportements à risque on va voir la
réponse en images
voyez vous sur cette image cette plante
en forme de grosse touffe
c'est une de ces plantes ornementales
extrêmement vaillante et on comprend
bien pourquoi est tellement
débrouillarde qu'elle arrive à pousser
en pleine ville au milieu de décombres
et là est-ce que vous la reconnaissez
c'est la même plante exactement qui
cette fois a posé ses valises à hawaï
une zone géographique à la biodiversité
autrefois foisonnante mais sur cette
plaine dégradé maintenant on ne voit
plus que cette plante à grosse touffe
les autres ne font plus le poids
et c'est aussi comme ça que la
biodiversité recul est bien évidemment
ce n'est pas la faute de cette plante à
grosse touffe mais celle du mammifère
bipèdes et présomptueux qui l'a emmené
ici
tous ces exemples montrent bien le
cercle vicieux qui est à l'oeuvre - on
apprend deux choses sur les plantes
moi on s'y intéresse et plus nos
décisions de chance d'avoir des effets
négatifs
encore une fois c'est vraiment comme une
langue si j'utilisais au milieu de ma
phrase un mot étranger que vous ne
connaissez pas vous auriez envie de le
comprendre
en revanche si je vous disais des
phrases en entier dans une langue qui
vous est inconnu aucun mot ne vous
intéresserait plus qu'un autre il ya
juste à trouver ce point de bascule à
partir duquel le domaine semble
suffisamment familier pour qu'on s'y
intéresse et ce point de bascule il est
souvent plus accessible que ce qu'on
imagine alors rapprochons nous en un
petit peu et pour commencer je voudrais
vous présenter une espèce que vous
connaissez peut être déjà et qu'on
appelle communément le gaillac
même si ce nom est un petit peu ambigu
est ce que vous voyez ces feuilles pas
ce ne sont pas des feuilles
ce sont des tiges très aplati qui assure
la photosynthèse et qu'on appelle des
pilotes vous ne verrez jamais les
feuilles d'un gaillac
à moins qu'il soit vraiment tout petit
sont tout petits ils font de trois
petites feuilles comme ça et après il
arrête complètement c'est un petit peu
comme nous avec les dents de lait est ce
que vous voyez ces fruits ces espèces de
grosses boules qu'on voit dans les
branchages
c'est pas des fruits non plus ce sont
des structures formé par des parasites
et qu'on appelle des galles ou dc 6 10
les fruits du gaillac sont en fait c'est
un petit goût sans forme de spirale qui
rappelle le nom latin de l'espèce
acacias spire orbis et je vous dirais
bien aussi que ces fleurs ne sont pas
des fleurs non plus mais je crois que
vous avez deviné larnack maintenant
effectivement ce ne sont pas des fleurs
mais des groupements de petites fleurs
des inflorescences donc une
inflorescence ça te ressemble à ça un
enfant l'essence complexe une sorte de
queue de renard ou alors ça peut
ressembler à ça une sorte d'ombrelles
qu'on appelle justement on belles
facettes une belle de carotte sauvage
regardez comme c'est bien rangé une
inflorescence ça peut également
ressembler à ça et oui les petites
languettes convoi ne sont pas des
pétales mais des fleurs individuel et au
centre également c'est un agglomérat de
petites fleurs en fête sur cette image
c'est un bouquet d'environ 35 fleurs que
vous contemplez alors maintenant qu'on a
vu certains types de fleurs est ce que
vous saurez répondre à la question de
quelle couleur sont les fleurs du
bouquin villiers
il ya les i j'ai entendu la bonne
réponse
effectivement au premier abord on aurait
envie de répondre rose fuchsia jaune que
16 mai les fleurs du bouquin villiers
sont invariablement blanche la partie
colorée et formé par ce qu'on appelle
des bractées les bractées sont départis
de l'inflorescence qui ressemble à des
feuilles et qui sont positionnées aux
alentours de la fleur
donc on a vu un arbre qui n'a pas de
feuille visible des fruits qui ne sont
pas du tout des fruits on a vu aussi des
fleurs qui sont des groupements de
fleurs des fleurs qui sont en fait
quasiment des feuilles mais les estomac
gourmand me diront peut-être
qu'importe la fleur pourvu qu'on ait le
miel et si je vous parlais maintenant
d'un miel que les abeilles arrive a
confectionné à partir d'une plante qui
n'a pas de fleurs vous avez peut-être
remarqué déjà mais les sapins n'ont pas
de fleurs et pourtant on a bien du miel
de sapin
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe si ce passé
qu'il ya des petits insectes comme des
cochenilles des pucerons qui viennent
s'installer sur les aiguilles du sapin
pour se nourrir de leur sève et qui
rejette ensuite par l'anus une déjection
sucré que les abeilles viennent ensuite
récupérer pour confectionner le miel de
sapin
une étude scientifique très sérieuse a
découvert qu'il s'agissait du caca le
plus délicieux de l'univers bonjour et
quand même lever une ambiguïté je suis
pas botan isse voit dans la vie je
travaille dans l'informatique mais c'est
justement en tant que nom botaniste que
je m'adresse à vous car pendant très
longtemps les plantes n'était rien pour
moi ou plutôt elle ne me parlait que de
moi mes préférences alimentaires
esthétique olfactives éventuellement
quelques souvenirs en s'attachant une
certaines contrées familière j'ai
commencé à apprendre le nom de certaines
plantes
il est environ trois ans à l'occasion de
chantier de reboisement un milieu
associatif
c'était la première fois que j'étais
amené à côtoyer de cyprès des plantes
qu'il ne serait d'aucune utilité direct
et c'est peut-être bien ça qui a laissé
de l'espace à la curiosité car j'ai
découvert que quand on commence à
apprendre sur les plantes on a envie
d'en savoir toujours plus et ça donne à
apprendre dans de nombreux domaines
alors la botanique
évidemment si l'écologie l'histoire la
géologie la nutrition le latin on
apprend sur les usages traditionnels des
plantes sur les pharmacopées on a envie
de les dessiner
bref c'est un régal pour l'esprit il ya
énormément de choses bizarres à
apprendre
est ce que vous saviez que les
cacahuètes poussé sous terre que les
figues ne sont pas vraiment des fruits
ou que cette insignifiante banane ou une
banane peut en cacher une autre que
cette insignifiante banane à plus de
gêne que la perte que la personne qui a
vu qu'il a bien rattrapé finalement donc
on a vu qu'il était de notre
responsabilité de mieux connaître les
plantes mais c'est une responsabilité
joyeuse qui va donner du sens à nos
actions et semer des petites graines de
bonheur dans notre vie c'est aussi
quelque chose qui va nous relier au
monde si on l'avait un petit peu perdu
de vue
car en effet quand on cultive son jardin
on profite d'une certaine qualité de
solitude qui est à la fois très simple
et très agréable et pourtant faire son
jardin c'est participer à un grand tout
s'est créé avec les autres le pollen se
diffuse les graines s'accroche aux
vêtements un jardin n'est jamais
totalement isolée du reste du monde
ça vaut aussi pour des terrasses et les
coins de fenêtre tout ce que vous
planterez dans votre vie même si ce ne
sont quelques pots de fleurs sur votre
balcon vous survivra d'une manière ou
d'une autre et se propagera à la manière
d'un message alors à vous de voir quel
est le message que vous souhaitez
envoyer au monde futur voulez vous que
votre jardin soit votre collection des
espèces introduites potentiellement
envahissantes ou bien un écosystème à
part entière qui nourrissent vos proches
dans le respect de la nature
environnante
ou encore un sanctuaire des espèces
menacées et oui vous pouvez en trouver
un pépinière les lieux où on
s'approvisionne en plantes sont comme
des dictionnaires
à vous d'y piocher les mots qui vous
survivre merci
[Applaudissements]